intercommunalité
inter communalités noms féminins des
joints et regroupements de communes qui
leur permet d'exercer ensemble certaines
compétences le principe de
l'intercommunalité c'est que l'oignon
l'union fait la force launay aussi du
même coup puisque l'intercommunalité
c'est une couche supplémentaire dans
l'organisation créée rite orial
française l'intercommunalité est comme
la laine que donne bonnion bas pas très
sexy mais comme l'oignon assez utile
elle permet une mutualisation des moyens
des financements et donc des économies
d'échelle et d'inde en principe une
intercommunalité est géré par des
représentants des colons concernés pour
les conseillers communautaires cette
année il y à du nouveau du côté des
communes de plus de 1000 habitants les
conseillers communautaires sont élus en
même temps que les conseillers
municipaux
youpi attention accrochez-vous à votre
échelle l'épluchage commence il va
falloir suivre les lecteurs votre liste
de candidats au conseil municipal et en
même temps ce pour une liste de
candidats au conseil communautaire aux
paupières sont lourdes sans pouvoir
séparer vie dont la liste des candidats
au conseil communautaire est plus courte
elle est par ailleurs établi selon la
technique du fléchage le côté la route
n'a rien à voir là dedans en gros mais
alors en très très gros un candidat doit
avoir la même place sur les deux listes
et pour ne pas en rajouter une couche
rassurez-vous les deux listes sont sur
le même bulletin comme quoi en amour
comme en politique si l'union est
indispensable l'oignon lui n'est
définitivement pas très sexy